uh Argentina everyone hey everybody good
to see a cinematic creeper in the corner
hey Jason hello everyone oh man weak
that chat [ __ ] freaking bigger house
every Swamper nice one um ah Google
search of red what's up look at this
great don't speak to the chat I got this
great shirt on today look at this
there's my two kinds of nerds friends I
don't I honestly don't know what this
part is making focus it's the Dragon
Ball Dragon Ball that's a Pokemon ball
it's together two at once like a MCS
your pain this is a Louisville Kentucky
[ __ ] nobody asked so today we're very
excited because we have we got access to
this thing called the Xbox game pass
which is this brand new thing Xbox asked
it came to us and we're like can you
talk about it and download something as
a player like yeah of course we love you
guys so to explain kind of what it is
here's our good friend Danny McBride
take it away Danny rip Lord dudes with
chainsaws chainsaw other dudes
anymore insanity juice will fill da more
Slayer
Oh give it to me
Xbox game pass only on Xbox one
so that's kind of a deal so we
downloaded a bunch of games that we're
gonna try playing today it's sometimes
we play before us that means we haven't
Beth looks way differences Jase that's
true
yep the first game we're gonna play his
little game called roundabout now listen
never heard of this game never no one's
ever heard of it it only has 2 stars
there's over a hundred games on the Xbox
game pass and this is one of them and so
we decided to start out strong I've
never seen this game before I've never
heard of it and I've heard of a lot of
games so let's play it all right and
again with after the Xbox game past 10
bucks a month you can download over 100
games this is one of the hundred games
so if you like a game then you get 20%
off if you want to buy it
oh cool just see we'll see if we're
gonna oh great start let's play later
yeah all right here we are
roundabout that's right that's right
music great somebody said this looks
like it's really into porn somehow it
kind of dies it does Oh
Garnier Fructis wants to know if you use
any specific a specific shampoo me use
Garnier Fructis I use Head & Shoulders
alright we got I don't nothing about
this game ooh
ready to play here we go this is
hilarious ah no pan seared yeah no pan
seared you get the whole game you could
play it for 30 days it's like the entire
game so you can beat if you can beat a
game of 30 days did you get to put the
game but if you want to own it past that
thank you then you have to buy it yeah
it's like renting it kind of it's
exactly if I can never rent it it yeah
it's very much like Netflix I kind of
think
there is Anthony what is what is going
on Mannis what is this limousine driver
well I'll be the this looks like
something you and I would make it also I
hope there's no actual game and it's
just a movie that they have oh yeah
Chris Murphy we're not sure if this is a
movie or not but it does see there's
like challenges and stuff this looks
like my kind of game
oh dude wait oh this is hilarious wait
oh my god wait this this game all of a
sudden got amazing this is amazing
oh no hit the stop trying not to man
it's harder than you think
alright I don't even know how to play
xbox this is insane things started that
made this game great at driving by the
way no stop by the wait house oh you got
to go no dude you got to go back in the
thing you're missing the point cuz
that's what you gotta follow the arrow I
think Microsoft has enough money yeah
you know so they don't need to really
I'm not sure was the money-making scheme
maybe they just want to help love yes
you passed yes this is insane that's the
driving test guys
somebody said please make it stop memo
love the Darth Vader this is how I would
drive look horrible excuse me couple mo
Donuts this is Josh alright alright
let's keep going let's keep going oh
you're killing a lot of people oh no
passengers everyone get out of there
it's true
presentation I don't understand I have
questions
yeah how does this first of all why is
this where do I go
Oh hit why or how that shot has happened
so many times you can you show me some
more my shop by the way he's a mechanic
wearing a dress shirt they were like all
right we only have budget for either
paint oil on his head or or jumpsuit
what should we do what conveys you gotta
kind of roll with it maybe I'm weirdly
good at this game
oh yeah don't kill these people this
went from fun doughnuts to vehicular
manslaughter really I didn't know that
was a thing i watch this move whoo slide
neuron see why's it rotating I have no
idea we don't know we missed that part
of the lure at the beginning it's
something about a black Steeler says
we're trying too hard but only use T oh
listen trying too hard too is gonna be T
oh oh I'm just trying to help you with
your insult yeah it's too hard yeah not
we're trying insult you yeah proper
grammar cuz I you know we wouldn't have
gotten the correct insult exactly so you
know if you're gonna insult somebody
don't be dumb idiot how about that all
right here we go I'm not look I'm just
getting oh no you know what that's not
my fault
they ran into they ran into the fence
and exploded a product oh my god these
people were
I'm making I feel like I'm making some
sort of you're making silicic selfie and
I you keep making money with these
people I'm not getting blamed for those
deaths a my two cents for something oh
you just made $5.99 by hitting that car
I don't know
he's like first of all two cents these
people suck at driving look at this I
don't understand how this car even works
by the way after 40 years this is what
video games - yeah I exploded cuz I hit
the grass it's good it's gonna be sad
when this is the best game we play the
whole day yeah here we go yeah this is
oh my god the girls are getting paid to
talk in those clips that was a bad
showing alright we played enough this
game yeah I think we know what this is I
can't play anymore in this we play next
alright there's a couple games we could
play out let's go target One Bowl you
don't play blood ball I don't know that
is it's like a football game yes with
works yes alright blue bullet your
scream ride what's that I don't know I
downloaded a bunch of games cuz of an
Xbox game pass you can download a bunch
of games go 30 days that's right
Flacco Jones is a great game awesome
game playing the cutscenes of the cherry
on top yeah I know I'm just closed
username I gotta say it was kind of cool
to see the weird patterns that I was
making on the ground it was cool cyanide
Studio play bud bowl so we're doing
that's what we're doing playing Blood
Bowl drunk-driving sim I'm not sure I
don't think anybody's a drunk driver
he's just done Donuts the entire time
yeah
I don't understand how that car works
yeah it was on like aren't the other or
the things just sideways oh no now we're
gonna get a bunch of that car basically
sits on like a desert chair and the
whole thing rotates around that you went
desk chair with I'll that's a terrible
idea for a microphone with spikes on it
just stab yourself in the face
this is like a football game with dice
and waiting what do you mean who maybe
who should do a friendly match to a
local friendly match a chopper oh yeah
I'm in this is a clean-looking control
yeah we just got one of those new Xbox
[Music]
guests we got to do this now
wait this is turn-based all right here
we go wait I mean this is turn-based as
I mean there's a race involved no
turn-based is like you take turns like a
board game what if this is turn-based
this is bullsh we're not playing who
makes a football game that's turned next
oh come on yourself like hydras punch
yourself in the face
you're the shirts razor claws I'm the
skirts razor claws skirts
hurry today's we did it hit a today at
the green button all right it doesn't
matter let's go to this league that
looks great moldy den Nick Nolte -
voiceover I'm Nick Nolte
watchman what was that movie where the
guy gets shot sorry I'm reading all this
fine print yeah why don't we the fine
print orange it's a video game of a
board game of a sport if you haven't
played it it takes a few hours to learn
the rules
oh this isn't great hod I think I I
think we're gonna be no ping out of this
game pretty stream ly fast okay yeah I
heard it takes a while velour not plays
who's gonna spend the time to play a
game called Blood Bowl - no offense well
if it's awesome I mean if it it doesn't
if it's like and everyone in the chat is
like no not awesome it's nothing if it's
like NFL Blitz with monsters I'm hoping
what's that game or you're like orcs and
then you're also humans you're trying -
what's that game guys I'm thinking of
it's an arcade game and you run that
forth
it's like pigskin I've never heard no
pigskin is great Lightning Hydra now
guys now we're gonna get like a ton of
notification these are
guys Angelo de la sombra that's my
secret capam always drinking let's go
let's go I don't need to see what we
look like here it's like a bunch of
people work at Hot Topic I don't the
airs yeah
oh there's here guys yeah there's a
bunch of people there's just everything
that lives in my apartment besides me
[Music]
don't trust geeks bearing gifts can you
guys please do the arm thing oh my god
Sunny Delight what are you talking about
what's the arm thing chicken LP okay no
no that I don't think I put I'll kick it
with sunscreen on his ears all they were
right oh okay okay we're not playing
this game
all right do your kickoff right or it's
gonna be done
you can even know how to do it no number
foot wheat oh those guys it's already is
terrible who made this game who made
this game let's take everything fun
about football and ruin oh my god look
look at the dice it's crazy see if you
can do anything I'm trying
challenge you do you really want to
confuse yes yes I do I guess yep I'm
gonna set up my team look the permit
[ __ ] out it looked like a great setup
yeah I'm moving this guy over he's the
dome yep hang in there all right
anyone who remotely like oh my god this
is terrible
oh hey Goku is watching this at 12:40 an
Indian trash-talking between two players
that generates them explodes what this
is the nerdiest
we're not playing we're not playing this
sorry you gotta get it sorry blood-borne
blood ball fans we're not playing this
case it's awful that's an awful game
don't download that game that's a 10
stream ride
oh yeah scream right let's try scream
yeah I feel like this is gonna be fun if
this is also turn bass we're quitting
stopping the stream immediately it's
just hope the vehicle of the ride is
spinning right now this is turn-based
I'm going on record to save this
turn-based we're quitting we're stopping
the stream and me here never I'm never
coming back the developers are cutting
their wrists don't make a turn-based
football game that's their fault nobody
this isn't football but it's all blood
ball it needs to be awesome I agree that
name is like 27
seems like you could simply blood ball -
what happened in Blood Bowl 1 they were
like ah you know what we really should
have put more rules in crash they've
said the board game is much better so
there's a board game that's not the
video oh well that would be cool that
would be fun
yeah if it's our games are great I agree
and you can we have the technology to
make it awesome what are you doing blood
ball - what are you doing meeting a
we're syncing data alright here we go
okay oh here we go career whoa oh and
bounce hosters ooh maybe it's like
roller coaster tycoon you know what
let's just yeah this could be fun
that's your career oh man you know what
[Music]
okay we don't KB's music how's it going
in these music the populous labs let's
just get into the screaming out of
riding let's get it you know what don't
I don't I don't need a tutorial on how
to do rivets I don't need a thing on how
to spend my money on different track
upgrades just get me into the screaming
get me into the ride eh yeah you know
apparently it's a board game that's been
around for 20 days you like a hacker hi
I say your name right
Raquel hey Raquel uh assalamualaikum
there you go right back at you okay so
what should we do here demolition expert
mmm I mean I think let's just do this
just do some let's just get into
screaming man yeah I'm gonna scream and
get into riding get into screaming get
into ride let's go let's go let's go and
I've time for this [ __ ] oh yes we
need to drive these boats around it's a
bunch of fencing dudes this is game of
my fencing hopes up if we get to drive
boats and helicopters
into this game especially weird
helicopters that have rotors that by the
way that the heli I just want to point
something out that kind of a helicopter
they hit wrote around the back is to
like do a turn so putting a rotor like
this doesn't work there see what I'm
saying yeah thank the wait helicopters
go forward is they tilt and then the top
one pulls them forward the back it was
just okay I guess unless you're trying
to do flips what is this here we go get
me into some screaming and get me to
some ride baby come on baby yeah oh
let's do it yeah
let's do it okay we'll figure it out
we'll figure it out what you're on a
track I don't think we'll figure it out
you know it oh dude see this I'm talking
about us is like a hard cut - what's
your first move yeah yeah roll the dice
oh yeah it's like a hardcore bobsledding
yeah let's go that's how I feel
well you're on a track do you have to do
anything I don't know I don't not sure I
mean you have to hit buttons and
something's happened dude you better get
over this okay I get the chair of the
early okay oh you know what you kind of
do have to do some leaning absent
bobsled I get oh can I come off the trip
I should keep looking back at me like
that I think she's on drugs there we go
change camera yeah this is a weird
bobsledding game it's not really Danny
just kind of a bobsledder
oh yeah lean coaster there we go I'm
gonna wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
boom I'm not going any faster the scheme
is nothing it's not making me scream Oh
God Jesus Christ
[Music]
maybe I'm not playing it correctly
alright that's it
you win well this is the first oh look
that was not that was not alright
alright let's let's keep that wasn't
really that was worth luck it yeah right
that wasn't a scream rod yeah you know
this is lame says mister tired man 81
yeah ah Morrow [ __ ] noogie pass it's
got a bunch of great games on it alright
Xbox game pass it's not just not just
blood ball
that's just played ball exactly we're
just playing some ones that we've never
seen before
alright come on because here's the great
thing you could try out games well I got
Spotify I'll go to Spotify all the
system you think I would normally listen
to you know you almost 170 million
screen rating whatever that means
Oh Maisie the arm thing what's the arm
thing touch of red yes we're off next
week
this is almost as bland as Ben's blood
pulse is cracking and let's not go crazy
all right you're right get a perfect
start derailer holster and score try
another actually I see one of you are
just gonna do a track thumb red switch
total okay I'm gonna try to derail you
get a million OD real points need to
move your body the same ways the dudes
in the ride make it real says these
music
so I needed Cool Runnings but it's like
thankful that's right
[Music]
perfect man she's I don't trust her man
she's like kind of like the friend who
never gets out and does anything she
isn't this awesome guys we're in a Prius
isn't this amazing it's uh yeah chill
out dude just chill out by the way no
one's wearing a seat belt can I point
that out oh dude how did you do that or
not I just press the button whoa you're
doing it now
you're the man now dog too late too late
[ __ ] who's nice bonus feel the rhythm
feel the ride this is you can actually
make your own tracks yeah but we don't
want to do it are you screaming I don't
see you screaming at all I see you
riding but I'll see any screaming
Anthony early too early because that's
so excited that's what's exciting about
rollercoasters boosting too early stop
is the heavy rail oh my god yeah I'm out
with this game all right all right let's
play something Ashley [ __ ] I know here's
a game I used to play a lot back in the
day little tack in second dude getting
plates you play oh yeah screaming
internally so silly
yeah MC Gary I agree like screamer I
could be fun like rollercoaster tycoon
is not the most fun game in the world
the first time you play but you get to
build a park that's sure you get to be
Walt Disney this Tekken Tag Tournament
is turn-based imagine of fighting you
know is turn-based have they made a
fighting in this turn-based yeah look at
our feet
oh yeah look at these gloves got a bunch
of marbles on our gloves it's gonna be
cool
Eddie I'm play Tekken since along I know
the 90s yeah oh here we go [ __ ] oh yeah
great great great great okay great great
great great what uh now dude if you were
a fire or should I say when you fight on
the street yeah what do you uh what's
what's your style what's your fights
time scrappy for sure what do you mean
scraps crabby style like what lots of
lots of weapons who already this is
awesome scrappy weapons you're gonna
want to it start the start button is I'm
so sorry
this mute you know what this should be
scream ride music okay what huh you just
what yeah nice who you want it let's go
tag man it is contact I won't tell you
oh dude
first of all this guy's the best I used
to play this so much yeah me too but
never Onix never I never tagged I never
played time
oh hell yeah I'd be a bunch of cats I go
to class wizard guy no what are you and
then bob's big boy yeah I'm team cats
because I feel like if anybody has an
allergy I already win you know it's my
dangerous yeah I come at you and I just
break out in hives totally exactly oh
yeah
bob's big boy huh it's like talk to the
hand
yeah over off him up good yeah cuz I'm
next yes right yeah dude
oh whoa yeah I'll punch this dude in the
face all day I'll punch this tea in the
face all day I can't look at this a
little I move my special punch smooth
yeah and no control why do you do that
yeah punch my face
oh yeah punch him in the face Oh fine
you gonna block that I'll kick you in
the face oh oh hey Bob sweet boys not
bad
[Music]
you got a tag out dude don't worry about
it
what about this move Wow oh wait can you
do like one handed what hand look at hi
no one can skip sucks give me back the
blood bowl I love blood bowl imagine you
wanna cheer team cats rear oh my god
that's right fawful dude
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right boom I'm a wrestler baby
oh thank jump I can't move forward or
backwards oh I can Jeff ooh
oh I've been using the wrong joystick
are you kidding me right now
oh that was great
I haven't been using this one how do you
even I don't even know how to choose my
other guy yeah oh yeah you well this
guy's good tons of [ __ ] oh my god just
broke that's an ACL oh how are you doing
the coolness
if you hit buttons at the same time
you'll do grabs oh [ __ ] him this is
great two joysticks it eases the hangul
hun low kick bro
[ __ ] that jab you're right Pablo you
want to probably cheat your character
yeah for sure just beating the living
crap out of you blame the care I'm gonna
go all babe's team cats man you got a
meme team babe now I'm gonna go babe one
I'm gonna do what am I gonna do they
able to do babes he's a Bears babes
versus bear if they the greatest names
in fairs the greatest matches yeah dude
Anna I agree man King was my boy back in
the day what's that mean we got a pic a
pic level hit a button o PG look up
tongue thing with the [ __ ] you talking
about you're having hell yeah guys
you're playing some games some old faves
and on Xbox game pass again it's 10
bucks a month it's pretty great we
although we have been playing dumb games
without reason we're gonna place it goes
hearsay now why do I have
I feel like blend easy why do you
floating on I feel yeah cuz I can't swim
pandas spent all their days up in the
trees god that's a big you guys were
afraid hey oh oh yeah this big oh yeah I
think I'm impregnating anything my Karen
oh I will say bears kind of are not made
to kick they got kind of short legs
oh I'm owning you though get this guy
out of here
bring back the Panda yeah I don't like
this chick either the cool brave oh ha
ha I land on my feet
you know I'm not good at kicking but I
am good at kicking you whoa Wow
what if this is like more of a sex thing
and these guys these are dudes in suits
who just like getting beaten up in very
costume I bet there's a fetish for that
probably
[Music]
here's another bear you can beat up why
don't you hit a poor defenseless bear
you know oh yeah that was just
embarrassing that was embarrassing
panda bear should rip that jugular yeah
I don't know how to do that
all right one more round I'm ready to
switch to another game but this game is
pretty dope yeah this is fun all right
I'm gonna do best hair all right and I'm
gonna go oh this [ __ ] I'm gonna
go this dude craziest beard for sure
I'm gonna go weird beasts weird beasts I
like that yeah weird beasts I'm the best
hair who's got the best hair this dude
is pretty great hair we got a nice suit
on oh that dude all right this guy
definitely has yeah I think this guy's
this guy's good bottom hair yeah I guess
lower hair will do it's a beard so that
ps+ Josh Martin hit Martinez you both
improve really quickly thank you it's
very nice to be said yeah I'm ready baby
oh man gross peace they're gonna be
awesome oh dude gross be swear I need to
see those guys yeah those guys are sweet
you've got a dinosaur different dude
this guy kinda looks like I was like I
have a stick eyes mouth what's his name
The Phantom Menace dude okay do we all
know you can't grow a mustache oh I'm
gonna smack doesn't seem right oh no
fires no way that's fair oh wait are you
tickling me I think it doesn't
that's my tickle tickle punch oh that's
it's just a big Jesus Christ oh god
that's right where's your God now
[Music]
give me my big guy
Oh ooh big boys only whoo he's not as
nimble duh oh you don't say it's like 9
feet tall how does a guy like get into a
restaurant oh that sucks let's just do
like find a seat in a restaurant nice
shoot anything oh yeah baby
my old guy oh that's cool give me my
mind me my man beast guy yeah I'm gonna
smack this dude down you know it's time
for the punch attack punch punch punch
oh no I'd say give me the tickles again
ah Timmy the hair swing is the best is
that your hair is that like a little
Jesus Christ
shoot anything
[Music]
let's get I climax yeah yeah just fly
over and then get you
oh yeah shocker I'm fighting like nut
dudes from the nether realm let's go to
another game all right let's get out of
here bloodbath again no I mean boy I
know you keep wanna playing let's make
Omega man yeah mega man dude oh dude I
love mega man oh can we play Saints Row
first I've never played this game or
actually you know we should play we
should play layers of fear sure it's a
slow burn it's scary
I've only played Tekken out of all these
scary game ball charts old man I don't
know how to do the bull charge
invincible daugther doubled a Mega Man
oh maybe we should play some Mega Man
yeah after this we'll play Mega Man
people want to see Megan let's just go
back to Megan yeah although I do want to
try I've never played Saints Row ever
any of them any of the saint's row game
so I really want to try so I got the
mini NES uh-huh and I've been playing
the old Megaman to a bunch o zu / fun
awesome
you want to start then sure this is get
more Megaman experience
god you're just watching where we're
screwing around on xbox game pass today
and for Xbox gold expects a lot of gold
members it's available now oh hell yeah
otherwise for everybody else it's
available June 1st and over a hundred
games it's super fun ten bucks a month
and you can even when you download the
games you play em for 30 days offline
and after you download them you go this
is awesome it's all the old mega yeah
let's do let's play a crazy one all
right you know what let's play the first
level of the first one and then the
first one of the sixth one and see how
they changed all right guys get is
awesome oh hell yeah
I feel like I gotta say something man
Mega Man doesn't get it to do oh you
know it's like there should be a dope
Mega Man move I agree there should
absolutely Reynolds as Mega Man as Mega
Man would be awesome or he'd be a better
air man with like a fan in there yeah
yeah oh you gotta go I expected Ice Man
deed yeah dude I love this game Thank
You me it doesn't get his due it's being
awesome it's always like Mario or
whatever this is awesome
this is so sweet oh my god I missed this
game wow you're dead you're immediately
dead you're gonna get killed by the
first guy oh my god the first guy you're
gonna kill the ice is the hardest did
that uh like you just slide along oh
come on you are getting your ass hill
this guy's impossible he's a mega
woman's is Andy I forgot you gotta give
you won't beat this levels this Colonel
Jim to cross Ike I'm figuring it out who
I've not watched the new Dragon Ball
super how is it oh yeah my shirt today
is half Dragon Ball Z hat Pokemon -
nerds coming together I don't know yeah
nothing is your friend in Megaman yes by
the way I will say this game Megaman
might be one of the hardest like oh this
is so hard the second one on NES is
insane it's so fun it's so difficult I
loved Megaman are you about to cancer
yes plus cancel it I haven't really got
any great games for PS Plus lately III
did back in the day but lately it hasn't
been awesome for me I you mother
yeah the fullness is great I mean again
like you have to you have to think like
Xbox they're just starting game pass so
they put like a wide range of games on
there yeah like Viva Pinata
well they also they also put like all
the gears of war on there which is great
ah dude I needed it though and again
they put a bunch of indie games on there
which is odd they put layers of fear
which if you haven't played will play a
little bit of it it's olives ladies if
you're super fun so you know they they
put it pretty good
they put a pretty good mix on there to
start off and they're gonna keep every
month they add games and they also take
away games so if you don't like the
games that around there now just wait
till next month
or yeah I can tell you just get killed
oh my god that why I matter dude I know
it's hard
what's rare replay I play that now watch
I'm gonna do even worse than you oh my
god hardest thing ever you can't kill
that guy we're gonna die right there
we're gonna die no way we can beat this
level I'm gonna die Kelly Reed says I
suggest using timing
don't play games should we just traffic
I made six
let's do Megan eight six let's see what
it looks like oh what's like the sounds
are loud the best alright now we're
gonna try playing Mega Man 6 1993 I
thought it said 1893 for sale is busy
already the Capcom's different in the
year 20xx
I agree Mario it's a shame we can't get
more classic Nintendo games on xbox
Megaman is is a masterpiece aw dude I
don't think I've ever played this one
here's my plant man it's bluish yeah
plant man is the word Blizzard man just
like a frat boy okay wait a second
you're lit you're basically Blizzard man
right now Jamie said you guys do the
same thing I did as a child I'm gonna
play all of them in order
oh god it's too hard plays the latest
one I love it whoo yeah dude here's war
forest super fun so nothing changed from
the first one yeah it's done sanely hard
the graphics are way better I'll say are
they well look you guys in the
background yeah yeah you have different
like oh that's good nothing blows up
that thing you can have a million other
harder things yeah they're like how can
we make this game harder brute force
porridge how do I feel that's how some
gamers feel about clueless gamers is
that it makes fun of games that gamers
expenses I've never actually heard that
clueless gamer makes fun of gamers at
their expense I think that actually it's
the opposite I think that Conan's the
[ __ ] and it makes gamers look good
because they own it's stupid but I will
say comedy is subjective and not
everybody likes everything so you know
some gamers that I personally didn't
even think we're that great people up
and the opposite some you know people
think some were terrible that I thought
were awesome so if it does if you feel
like you're a gamer includes gamer has
made fun of you trust me
I apologize a and trust me that is
definitely not too intense
[Music]
come at me
who's searched I know it surges like the
drink
yeah I'm researching good McGary thank
you I'm glad that yeah oh you have to
learn a slide move dude yeah no [ __ ]
you're gonna want to not stand next to
the bum when it goes come on Jesus
Christ
I do love like he's like oh yeah that's
that's right
Guarnere Fructis yes exactly I agree
it's awesome when like Terry Crews or
Elijah Wood are what those people show
up and play games it's awesome Bombo
24-hour man don't worry I call them
Conan stupid all the time and that's why
I get beaten up wait greatest things
about Meghan oh so challenging couldn't
just burn through it
in fact you're paying 50 $60 for a game
you want it to last
I agree it's challenging nature actually
made it one of the greater games and I
will say this is actually a super cool
thing not to get too philosophical about
video games guys but back at now you
have all these power-ups right and you
have like unlimited continues and it's
basically a game for the most part if
you just keep at it long enough you'll
beat any game that wasn't true with
games back in the day you only had a
certain amount of lives you know you had
to get going again to be better you did
you couldn't get power-ups you just had
to get better yeah you had to make
yourself oh yeah you guys late except
okay no you're right that's true you had
to figure it out
keep sipping my drink backseat gamer
Thank You Arpita whoa that's right who's
the best celebrity clueless gamer what
do you mean by that's the best gamer
they played with yeah who's the best
celebrity Garry the best actual like cat
good at video games I don't know it's
hard to say like Lil Wayne was great
really yeah how do you yeah I mean like
Wiz was great
Alijah they're all good like Terry Crews
was awesome like at playing video game
yeah absolutely
Jesse Bell says something to be said
about this for the story of the game
he's didn't have any that's true I think
what we've what we've traded out for our
will be trade it out like like timing
and ability for story
but to that point I like the old simple
stories like of Mario where you're just
like saving the princess zelda I mean
obviously they're more complicated now
the new Zelda's there's young dogs in
robot seal costumes yeah
[Music]
what is no wait a second there's I guess
oh how you double it's just why we'd hit
why lets you shoot like it a butler oh
that's like there was some slide moon
alright that's like alright Mega Man
guys pretty fun yeah it's pretty cool
yea-ah
let's put layers of fear this one's cool
alright it's kind of a fun indie game I
first play this on steam it's really
great it's very scary to be the opposite
of Mega Man it's gonna be very pretty
but very it's have a slow burn a charged
shot exists that's what it is
somebody's putting up Rhea Rhea lotta
saving video game females Mega Man it
was a female know uh Mega Man was not a
female oh you're thinking of Sheamus
there Saint Samus Santa's from Metroid
Samson famous oh no what did you need
Conan here to make fun of you yeah what
is your favorite game I've never asked
oh dude by the way this is actually a
good thing read this guy's ear epileptic
don't watch this part of the stream
Jesus what's not what favorite game a
favorite game i don't know well braid is
pretty fun which we played before i
downloaded it on here also it's also by
the way you could play braid on Xbox
team pass which is awesomes one of my
favorite games of all time
thanks cold cold salt or the people want
saints row oh you want saints row
alright alright I've never played Saints
Row by the way I don't know what it is
let's try it it's like Grand Theft Auto
on acid somebody said here you go whoa
yeah Saints Row it is what is layers of
fear about somebody's asking no make
sure you wake up in those house
you wake up in this house you don't know
what the deal is you don't know where
you are who you are you're trying to
figure it out and all these people have
been murdered and it's crazy it's pretty
fun yeah here we go time voltage so your
skin feels a kind of intense uh no car
guy layers of fear is great that's a
really fun game I played about half of
it when the demo came out really really
fun press the menu button Brad know who
co-op campaign
let's look co-op hi co-op options
[Music]
friendly fire friends only private open
to all friends on private there's not
gonna be any local is there get out of
here for singing compete now get out of
here we can't play dog let's go campaign
sentro for stupid with fun and three and
two are ultimately better what's the
what's the point of saints row like
what's the story behind saints row does
anybody now know split-screen co-op
because of the draw bad lame
I need another system says motor butter
fair enough I know music privateeer
people joins us Jason so is this like a
in the future Game of Thrones you're
wearing a bunch of hockey equipment
there's a throne alright
maybe somebody says you're you're the
president the world's been attacked by
aliens and you're stopping them you're
the president that's pretty cool
here we go thanks Perry nice to see ya
it's gangsters in space whoa oh you were
the leader of a gang you fought off
other gangs and you became president
you're a story I thought this is like an
open-world game
oh boy I'm gonna suck at this game I
think Hado ray Egon oh you're a Call of
Duty girl specifically zombies alright
let's go [ __ ] run up run over there
and kill some people it's just this
beginning sequence it takes 20 to 30
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
I mean normally left triggers aim right
trigger shoot yeah right stick down
rights to head pressing the right stick
present Oh Phil this terrorist dude
[Music]
skin for our core can I blow that up
you're wearing a really slim fitting
shirt yeah nice I'm not sure you should
be that close to like toxic
whoa good night Ali nice shits going
down man oh boy
yeah there's no limit to the number of
games you could download all hundred
games that are available on X Xbox game
guys
there's only storage baby storage is
your only limit he passes unlimited play
yeah that's true
[Music]
oh the maillard oh I'll take a look
today this game is totally what it looks
like what I looks like something's that
oh those guys back there yeah this is
kind of like who's the president
Harrison Ford and heir for that one
really beats the [ __ ] out of people your
base of the Harrison Ford in this yeah
oh this is like air force - air force -
there's no this is like Air Force One -
hmm you know how do they do that if
there's like you know what I'm saying
like you know Ed Burns made that movie
she's the one what if they did a sequel
she's the one - how does it even work
she's also she's the one again hello T
oh oh I keep getting these guys truth
Nukem this is saints row 4 I think I'm
not good with Roman numerals it's IV so
maybe this is saints row IV you know I'm
saying you get an IV or something hey
can this the Saints Row 4 we're playing
we're trying out Xbox game pass today
which is free right now it's not free
it's available right now for Xbox Live
Gold members and it's gonna be available
for everyone else - first it's ten bucks
a month hundred games to pick from but
you can download all of them and they're
all full games which is great you can
play the entire game
I never pretty good mix on that right
now it's like we just played Mega Man
all like one through six playing Saints
Row 4 all the gears wore on there you
got your halo 5 guardians on there and
you've got other things like whoa Blood
Bowl - if you so desire a football game
that's also a board game and they change
games every month
I got it checking LP thank you you can
stop writing it this game is hardcore
[Music]
air force in space after so many sequels
it's not making money completely new
director plot builder a random site
creature I am horribly wants to do this
game on pass
that's a good question Chris I don't
have a list by QV I mean an Xbox comm
they have the whole list of all the
games which is pretty cool really bad
name oh whoa
what should we try T Virus yeah good
thing it's the being a summer exactly
chicken LP please I remember Phil don't
win doc try not to shoot the toxic waste
or maybe just shoot the toxic waste yeah
sure I was trying to you can't blow up
toxic waste Alamos I don't know I felt I
don't think they change all the games
I'm not sure about that I think they're
they add ones and take one those
explosives and chemical cyclases so
thank you yes you
oh there's money you'd have me I was
excited I thought it was gonna be open
to world and I realize it's like on
Rails Shh
seriously just bad a name not using this
controller only red barrels exploded
shooters Kelly Reed exactly
load up dude shoot the red barrel Kelly
read that he had explosions going off to
you yeah that one's for you Kelly
that's my team
oops maillard oh maybe they will got it
thank you waffle tarts I kind of figured
that since they wrote it 50 times why is
there a picture of most def up on the
right and a fedora
well I suppose stuff in this game touch
of red maybe well what should we do when
we reach five million subscribers on our
YouTube channel what should we do party
yeah pizza party pizza party pizza party
or a pudding party I love pizza parties
but I also love pudding parties guys I
love any kinds of parties the Rexton
philosophy och Row 2 is the best Saints
Row maybe I should start up a Saints Row
2 what am i doing which one is this
watch this stream from the Pakistan
hello Rene oh thank you for watching
[Music]
uh Josh Jordan does come down every once
in a while
not today we just come down here we go
[Music]
killed Oh moving don't trip over these
cords that are all over the floor well
it's a slow motion where you're shooting
in the knee cast shoot him in all the
non-vital areas and just let them die
slowly that's what I like to do
oh it's like a Western in here Oh Jase
Cyrus dude Miley Cyrus is the virus
we'll get you my let's get er falafel
parties delicious I love falafel Oh
oh damn oh they got them for me Miley
Cyrus oh my take that Miley wear like a
hey you're never gonna sing again
I don't know perfect cliffs is that a
new thing I'm not sure I'm not in charge
of that chase person who Francesca Malto
oh my god I'm Marvin 120 complaint
saints row 4 there's gas that Lisa oh
whoa yeah love the hero jump terrible on
your knees by the way I can't wait for
Deadpool to I'm super excited to today
hey boys yeah yeah oh damn dude fight
this dude trying he's got a big as he
turned into Tekkit ball game that's a
knife over the top action baby
Oh dick thank you your dicks in your
stomach that's we usually see your
doctor yeah
QuickTime event
oh damn son damn son don't let him get
the gun your app they gotta get that was
the lamest jump in the lava or goo Ice
Ice Cube
oh dude I think he's gonna turn to a
matzah here I gotta get out of here go
go
we definitely just created a bad guy you
know you ever know that feeling you're
like oh yeah oh you just created a
killing final chance to say goodbye
are you gonna run it you just gotta know
how to roll to the missile site doesn't
say like leisurely stroll to the missile
silo oh my god
holy [ __ ] missile about it by the way
that's not the way that's not the way to
get on a flight yes let's let your
overbook that's not the way to get on
what is what played Saints Row 4 hey hey
dude you're not paying attention listen
arrows yeah I know could you not kill us
please
I've gotten us this far it's cold up
that's why it's in your stomach sister
oh yeah oh this is all over the top
action my goggle what was dooms
reference RT yeah oh my god this guy's
like super I like the fact that Isis is
music for this for this ah oh no I
haven't read by nature I haven't seen
the locusts honest trailers Ryan
Reynolds that was super nice I talked to
him in a Comic Con for a while just like
101 it was great New York and we talked
about Deadpool - it was cool we need to
talk about Deadpool - we just talked
about his feelings
my favorite thing about the first
Deadpool I love the the breaking the
fourth wall was awesome
I thought the action was fantastic fight
choreography was great Ajax was a great
bad guy
Colossus look good that's fine
it could have been more x-men in it yeah
yes I kind of liked it there only a
couple things cool the game we're done
that's great don't even need 30 days for
that game and now now it's a pudding
party guys you know what I want to say
something to you guys out there enough
pizza parties let's start more pudding
parties you know pudding pudding is down
putting you know who is putting anymore
nobody let's make pudding cool again
like a tapioca party like a tapioca part
now that's I think something else is
that not pudding I don't know saving
little things yeah
tapioca party what was the name today
the pudding that comes in like vanilla
and chocolate at the same time Kevin
fun packs or something putting packs
snack pack
thank you scruff three I agree I agree
but they did it so well in the movie
they broke the fourth wall so great so
well also I love like the his roommate
the old woman was really funny the baby
hand was funny TJ Miller who by the way
is on the show tonight TJ Miller we got
a lot of fun stuff planned I was great
in Deadpool I thought it's well written
you know I love Deadpool it's great
tapioca like a Billy Madison exactly
pudding party all right let's just start
the game start the game dude we don't
care probably have to go back and work
soon let me up creation do it except
what time to figure out one yeah cuz
it's one appreciate mm-hmm ah I just
gotta go everybody bye everybody bye RJ
this is fun thank you maybe next time
we'll play Blood Bowl again yeah Blood
Bowl 2 never forget thanks dude later
Yee O'Malley Patrick Stewart said he'd
love to cameo in Deadpool no kelsey
Grammer's beast to be an awesome
Deadpool side character that's [ __ ]
back there Top Ramen what kind of yarn
are you offering this guy's if you're
just joining us we are playing Saints
Row 4 which is great or playing it on
xbox game passage is great it's $10 a
month and available now for Xbox Live
Gold members and June 1st for everybody
else's some good news
[Music]
now grace now I get to go to a press
conference it says so this morning we've
got enough right now hey Keith David
look that guy the thing is one of my
favorite horror movies wow this is great
I think we have cancer man cuz people
are just gonna continue getting hungry
you know cancer had a good run cancer
didn't have a good run
cancer was terrible killed a lot of
people no Kenzie's keeping the source at
bay ah Chris I might be t3 people say
you can cram your agenda Congress you
are in for a rude awakening cause it is
word in politics filibuster
yeah he is Keith David that's great
punch a dick in the head punch a
[ __ ]
all right so far I've cured cancer and
punched a dude in the face just while
walking down the hall is this what being
president is like dr. Kelly I'm not sure
but this guy is not cool no I don't
party with dudes who look like they're
were the lead character and devil might
cry
by the way crib all right my trial that
guy got past security by the way but
whatever definitely pushed that guy this
is like where our country is going by
the way it's a little nerve-wracking
one word hummus it's going places now
wait a second I do like a good hummus
but I will say I think hummus is a kind
of pudding I'm gonna go out there and
say I think you could make the category
of pudding isn't just chocolate veal or
whatever it's a it's a it's a texture
it's a substance good why is hummus not
just chickpea puddings that's my
question for you what makes it what mix
of pudding guys discuss amongst yourself
you know hummus is a delicious savory
pudding okay
it's a dip now see there's different
food dips and puddings pudding you can
eat straight Ivete hummus straight oh my
god well I think we skipped a lot of
stuff there might have been a mistake oh
my god we just skipped the greatest
cutscene of all time not crap
[Music]
all right well sorry guys I kind of
screwed up on that can I take this
dude's gun or what well there's a bloods
plane studying why is there blood
spreading here and I haven't nothing is
there I miss his [ __ ] I need to take
over the world
boo putting is usually dairy-based not
the putting I've eaten all synthetic
baby please open the head I knew it
there's no bronze bust anymore
that's not oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
let's go it's great I don't a shotgun
[Music]
how do I change my guns
holy [ __ ] what is this thing Arby's
jeans that's cool that's pretty fun how
do I switch guns again oh yeah this is
great
so many guns you guys
[Music]
all right let's start off the old Swan
sng you know savory pudding yep oh Jesus
no Keith David nice strafe you know
right in the butt
[Music]
it's going on you know what you're the
president you don't need to swear the
walls would break but you know what I
think the Oval Office is like a
fortified or something so maybe that why
are they taking people I never
understand that I've used the technology
chuckle oh okay I shot a lot of cool
guns in Vegas over the weekend I got
like the Call of Duty package so I shot
like everything they haven't call it
duty which is pretty cool
and I'm a giant bruise on my shoulder
from it get out of the way you know what
it's calls for a little extra little
something extra you guys want to go out
of the way for a second that didn't work
at all
a bunker that's right anal probing
that's where the aliens think to enter
the brain and then I'm just screwing
with us you know literally screwing with
us a co t package yeah it was crazy man
and I have a giant other you see it I
still have a huge bruise on my shoulder
I you can't see it it's like this big
ak-47s by the way when you shoot them in
real life
really hurt they're not fun guns issue
luckily all these aliens are exactly the
same height
[Music]
I take any of their guns or what's the
deal here
I'd like to use an aliens technology
against them like in Independence Day -
you know hey Joe pick what's up by the
way physics I know you guys have ever
read any books I kind of like some of
those books that are about movies like
you know the science of interstellar or
the science of Independence Day or
something and in one of those books I
read that well this is a giant freaking
gun
I read that uh really they would just
have to all they would have to do is
just fly their giant ships over stuff
and that that's how they would destroy
because the ships to be up in the air
you have to displace a certain amount or
anything and just flatten everybody you
don't I'm saying oh whoops I guess I'm
supposed to be shooting this stuff
cool
you know what don't come get it taste
stay away taste it's gonna taste like
bullets in depth so you probably don't
want to taste that's our guys
luckily they're just flying by and doing
nothing
oh this is real bad
[Music]
I'm just raving like a lunatic why don't
I pass some legislation
[Music]
maybe we should like get like global
support you know where's Jeff Goldblum
[Music]
I think I have unlimited ammo so far
with this gun for sure
yeah it's just a polished piece of
bitters exactly its keeper Sutherlands
role as president jack bauer mixed into
one awesome role yeah build a wall
exactly to pickup build a big space wall
to keep the aliens out should I still be
shooting or what's up
I'm shooting at the giant ships
anal cavity fill the roof
I left there's an ear on the left ah I
got it
oh there's one guy who hasn't shot me
well now he's dead whoo I'm doing the
John Cena thing this president is a
douchebag oh man come on why would they
blow that up it doesn't have any
significance at all by the way
Jesus it's a massive entering our
atmosphere alone would kill us already
that's why I read somewhere about
friction with the planet exactly
something that's a quarter size of the
Moon would just destroy the earth period
[Music]
send Captain America there I just saw
Captain America's Civil War brother that
was awesome they like to get the
landmarks
it's like Mars Attacks Jesus oh whoops
is that Peter Dinklage oh my god is that
Dinklage that's awesome
John Cena's not a douchebag John Cena is
so cool that he can pull this off
without being a douchebag
John Cena by the way I think his granted
more wishes for the make-a-wish
Foundation than anyone else so he's like
a better person than 99.9% of the people
on the planet he had a better wrestler
[Music]
imagine instead of hair you just had
spikes how easy would that be in the
morning I mean you have to be careful
shampooing yourself but otherwise it's
fun this guy Oh gotcha and Roz I was
fighting Loki mmm this dude would kill
anybody that is Dinklage right
[Music]
is this Dinklage
[Music]
oh-oh-oh
so I'm dead right I'm so dead there's so
much blood coming out of me la dev yes
but that's the point that's cool t
virus-infected I'm excited for the new
Thor movie it looks amazing
[Music]
no I meant some kind of weird alien
thing you guys have watched mr. robot by
the way when they did that weird fantasy
for God flashback it was awesome oh this
is crazy like my dance moves though so
crazy right
star hacker what game this game this is
great this is really cool this is a fun
game awesome
next close gamer I think we're shooting
it next week or two weeks is the best
part of the whole game since Tiger this
game is awesome by the way
I can't believe I'd never played since
also I just love any game that i cain't
carves look at these cars
oh I haven't seen the new a garden to
the galaxy movie I miss in the first one
mr. robot was amazing I can't wait for
the next mr. robot the season extra
season just robot I ran into emmy rossum
at starbucks a little while ago because
they shoot shameless right on the lot
and it's really early and it was just
her night Starbucks and I wanted so bad
to ask her about mr. robot her husband
or a boy I Sam s smellin her together
I'm not sure if they're married or not
but Sam I suppose the guy does mr. robot
I just wanted to nerd out so bad instead
I was like I like your shirt that's it
but I wanted a scrub is robot that's
right yeah okay I think this is
incredibly creepy I want to you know
what for the rest of the day I'm gonna
walk around like this guy
this is great cautiously accelerate I'm
not driving by the way Emmy Rossum is
incredible yes very much so comedy kills
by the way I'm not steering I'm just
accelerating we're almost there
this would be creepy to live in this
kind of attempt and this pancakes
where's the pudding exactly that's I'm
talking about touch of red I should
totally that jaunty walk next time sank
fenêtre I've to hum a jaunty tune as
well well but she'd be more jaunty maybe
that's my maybe that's my late years
resolution be more jaunty you was a good
driving that's the shaking the poop out
loud
I know car guy well it's kind of hard to
do viewer stuff though for for stream
Coco because I can't see you guys I
can't see the there's a little bit of
pain which means something flash also I
started get out for the first time last
night which is awesome and we all know
what snapping pictures does don't we
night captain this is saints row 4
your public is wait let me set if you
can't handle it then you should try to
eat it delicious pudding
my dad yes I fall out did a great
Pleasantville spoof also so did hitman
there's another one that's great they're
all aliens dude come on get out oh boy
oh boy time to beat everybody up
let's punch him
[Applause]
[Music]
time to start punching oh this is great
look at this this is so fun
holy [ __ ] great jump into the car by the
way I'm out of here suckers let's go
cautiously accelerate my girl Kenzie Z a
lot of people walking around I think
there's too many people in this town oh
damn it I knew it
we're trapped in some kind of dumb
oh thanks T Simmons gotta go dig a hole
and get back to your power frame
someone's been playing a little too much
fallout or not enough I did use hand
signals remember kids if your blinkers
don't work you can use a hand signal
hard to do that in music controller
though oops sorry
sorry don't run across the street
there's a lot of milk men in this town
by the way oh sorry
a lot of milk men in this town I'm not
touching the I'm testing again dude
Truman shows one of my favorite movies
of all times I can't play this game
anymore kids nope
all right well on that you know guys I
think we're basically done for the day
again today we played I was really fun
to play an Xbox game pass it's available
now for Xbox Live Gold numbers 10 bucks
a month you know hundred games including
saints row before
layers of fear which you didn't get to
play but it's incredibly fun Megaman
telling all these great games and they
change games out every month and thank
you for joining us before we leave we're
gonna leave you a little message from
our friend Danny McBride get ready
thank you guys we'll see you guys not
next week but the week after because we
won't be here I'll be around Sunday on
my own twitch channel twitch.tv slash
Aaron Blair and watch tonight we got TJ
Miller on the show miss oh and who else
who else is on the show tonight and
another great another good and Lennon
Lennon Parham Lennon Parham is also on
the show tonight so as well of course
great comedy and I'm like so here's
Danny McBride a little message for Al
thank you for watching guys we'll see
you guys next time
I need more sweaty finger grips more
dudes with chainsaws chainsaw other
dudes anymore insanity juice will fill
da more Slayer Oh give it to me Xbox
game pass only on Xbox one
you